good morning john so maybe it has not
escaped everyone's notice that we
are up to something two different
subscriptions to two very different
products what are these boys doing well
let me tell you several years ago we
realized something obvious that there
are many things that people want and
need drinking a delicious cup of coffee
for example is a tremendous joy for many
people including for me putting on socks
that are art made by artists and having
people point to them and go i like your
socks or sometimes people point at them
and go i have those too that's also a
happy feeling and people are gonna buy
socks and they're gonna buy coffee and
they're gonna buy a lot of other things
and what you and i are trying to figure
out john let's let everybody know the
secret is can you make those things
really well and have people really love
them and have it be a great experience
for them and
build something really weird and unusual
which is companies that give away all
their profit so instead of the money
going to make the lives of the owners
better it goes to make the world
generally better now when we talk about
this stuff with people like we're
getting advice from they often say like
why are you doing this why would you
work so hard creating a business that
you do not benefit from financially and
why spend 15 years building up a
community on the internet only to
monetize it for somebody else and i have
two main answers to that question the
first answer used to be because we have
plenty now which is true we have plenty
now but when i said this to people in
like the business world they were often
quite incredulous because of course they
know lots of people who have plenty and
yet are still interested in more so
here's the refined and i think actually
more accurate version of that answer at
this point we are more interested in
impact than wealth i would not work half
as hard as i do on the sock club if it
was just about me making more money and
i know that that is also the case with
you and the coffee if we didn't have
partners in health's work there to
excite us i just don't think that we
would be as ambitious as we are but
second thing i think that this is an
even bigger deal the thing that has
excited us about this for 15 years has
not been building a community so that we
can make a living it's been building a
community and one of the most amazing
things about communities is when they
can build things together an example
from nerdfighteria like i feel a lot of
personal pride in crash course because
it's a wonderful thing that helps a lot
of people it has a lot of value but i
also feel a lot of community pride in
crash course because the people at
complexly and the people who wrote the
scripts all our freelancers and thought
cafe and everybody all came together to
make that thing with each other and that
was the community but also maybe the
thing about it that i am most proud of
is that it would never have been able to
get funding and it would never have had
its initial viewership that sort of
carried it forward and helped it grow if
it were not for this community crash
course is something nerdfighteria built
and that is true for so many of the
things that we have done i don't see
them as things i did i see them as
things that we did and i feel that way
because it's true i think that this
community could have been somewhat proud
of a sock club for profit like it's a
thing that we made together and like we
work with artists and we create art
socks that people like to wear i feel
that way about lots of projects that
youtubers do i feel that way about holo
taco and about dropout tv but we are
lucky enough to be able to ask what is
the best and coolest thing that we can
do with this activation energy and it is
stuff like delicious ethically sourced
coffee that gives all of its profit to
chair and i don't think that this is a
small or even medium-sized idea i could
be wrong been wrong before but i think
it's possible that someday there will be
awesome coffee club subscribers who have
no idea who hank and john green are that
to me is the best outcome that this
community builds things that spread
across the world doing good and making
people happy and making the world a
better place with people having no idea
that that's something we did already the
coffee club is doing a tremendous amount
of good i think it's donated already a
hundred thousand dollars to partners in
health and also every bag delivers two
dozen delicious cups of coffee so
there's that benefit as well no matter
how big it is i hope that you who are
watching this know that whether or not
you want this coffee or not and it's
fine if you do i hope that you feel the
same pride as i do in the impact that
this community has had john congrats on
the launch i'll see you on tuesday also
yes you can still sign up for the club
at awesomecoffeeclub.com